some of the scuttlebutt to keep it in
football parlance is that we've already
entered garbage time in this presidency
we're a quarter of the way in and there
are loud conversations being had about
2024. okay one of them on the edge of
town is of course hillary clinton who
wants to parade back into the town if in
fact they get killed in the midterms as
some type of centrist savior for the
party if we were just straight water
cooler talking not inside baseball
people we know in washington
i don't believe she's capable of giving
up on the presidency i'm not telling you
she's going to win it but could you can
see there's a world where she's going to
take the pantsuit out of the rafters and
give it another go that's funny uh yes
it will definitely come off the hanger i
can see it happening
i won't guarantee it but i i can see
how that could proceed let's say okay
but if i'm joe biden i don't want to
give up on this thing yeah no i mean not
this soon yeah heck no but but but
here's the problem for him i i believe
if he if if if you want to attack back
to a more moderate presidency
you know the progressive movement your
party's not going with you yep and
that's the problem and i i think they've
been trying to avoid that for a year i
think what else is interesting is so
many people are writing and suggesting
coming on fox and these are democrats
too some a lot of analysts that like
fire someone yeah well who do you fire
and they're saying ron klain i
i mean there was a big piece in the new
york times yesterday brett stevens was
writing about it said get rid of claim
and give someone who is the equal to joe
biden he suggested someone like tom
daschle i don't know if that's the
answer but i think what they've been
trying to do is keep a tourniquet on
this whole
center-left part of the democratic party
and the progressive left and up until
about a couple weeks ago i think they
were successful
but they're moving into a different
phase of his presidency and listen if i
if i were buying i want to be a success
yeah i don't want to have the last 12
months hanging on my record
i want to find a way yeah find a way to
win on something